à l'ailé gauche à la broche je suis là
pour défendre mes droits pas pour le
sacre
d'un côté des salariés mobilisés
de l'autre des clients qui veulent
passer depuis ce matin ce magasin
carrefour de dijon est partiellement
bloqué par ses employés ils manifestent
contre le plan social annoncé fin
janvier par la direction de l'ens saigne
une action coup de poing qui ne fait pas
de limite à houten de parler comme ça je
parlais faire ses courses c'est un peu
ennuyant quoi je trouve ça normal qu'ils
essayent de défendre leur pas après je
suis pas persuadé que la grève soit le
meilleur des solutions qui dit week end
pascal dit affluence alors pour
restreindre l'accès au supermarché et se
faire entendre
les grévistes ont utilisé des chariots
un barrage filtrant qui a suscité des
tensions
il ya une cliente est passé qui
voulaient passer je lui ai dit non et là
la communion c'est que elle voulait
absolument passer je les ai retenu et
elle ma peau est simplement griffés pour
pouvoir passer et puis du coup elle est
passée 16h15 le barrage est finalement
levé pour raisons de sécurité les
clients investissent à nouveau les
rayons
derrière eux les salariés restent
mobilisés leur principale revendication
toucher une prime de participation aux
bénéfices de 600 euros contre 57
aujourd'hui carrefour s'est engagé à
leur verser un intéressement
supplémentaire en début de semaine un
geste jugé insuffisant faut savoir que
c'était une tactique financière est
calculé deux pas de la part de nos
dirigeants
tout simplement afin de calmer lors du
préavis de grève les salariés pour
éviter la grève
donc les salariés ne sont pas dupes ils
savent très bien que les 350 euros était
déjà prévu d' avance donc les 400 euros
était prévu d' avance si on fait le
cumul des deux d'intéressement de
participation
les salariés attendent désormais une
réaction de leurs dirigeants sans
réponse de leur part ils se disent prêts
à de nouvelles actions